in these exit pole results you see a
Mars and Venus Universe for Haley and
Trump coalitions here interestingly on
the point about the crossover people
voting for Nikki Haley here's some
numbers from CNN about how the rest of
the night might play out let's go back
to David challan with that and David
you're getting more on the ways that
Republican primary voters don't see eye
to eye yes that's right Jake in these
exit pole results you see a Mars and
Venus Universe for Haley and Trump
coalitions here take a look look at the
numbers among Trump voters 70% of them
according to our exit polls are
registered Republicans Donald Trump his
support 27% of his voters are registered
Undeclared or Independents uh 3% were
unregistered before today look at how
that compares with Nikki Haley it's a
complete reversal it's an alternate
universe among Haley voters 70% are
registered Undeclared only 27% are
registered Republicans we also see this
with when asking people did Joe Biden
legitimately win the 2020 election which
he did among Trump voters 80% say no
they say it wrongly no Joe Biden did not
legitimately win the 2020 election haly
voters it's the complete opposite 83% of
haly Voters say correctly that Joe Biden
was the legitimate winner in 2020 only
15% of her voters say wrongly that he
was not this is the Trump Haley Mars
Venus election tonight in New Hampshire
all right David thank you so much
interesting stuff uh andw and I've been
speaking to voters all day and there's
really been two types of Voters
generally who I've been speaking to one
registered Democrats who are writing in
Joe Biden as a show of solidarity a
symbolic show of solidarity with the
president and the other would which is
an Undeclared voter who has a more
liberal leading ideology and who seems
to be voting for Nikki Haley almost
strategically and one of those voters is
with me right now Christian a freshman
from Dartmouth un or Dartmouth College
rather Christian who did you vote for
and why yes so thank you I voted for
Nikki Haley and it was certainly a
strategic vote um I think that the DNC
is fairly Resolute in their nomination
for Joe Biden uh and while I wouldn't
vote for her in a general election
particularly on our differences with uh
climate change solution and women's
right to bodily autonomy or
incarceration rates I think a vote for
Nikki is helps diminish Trump's
influence in the RNC and their
nomination but is also a vote towards
democracy and Christian is emblematic of
so many conversations that I've had here
throughout the day Rachel all right
that's CNN for you it's very serious
stuff a lot of money spent on graphics
and scary music it's kind of funny to me
it's like is that Brian stelter's uncle
they were like we fired that one portly
asexual guy get me somebody else to
analyze the number somebody a little
older he'll be more trustworthy anyway
it's just worth noting again I don't
have to reiterate it again it's just
worth noting who those crossover people
went to and you can either then say okay
that means that they're not really
Republicans and they'll never vote for a
Republican or you could say oh these are
people who could potentially vote for a
republican like Nikki they just will not
vote for
Trump